all right
we are now live for november's
uh political theory and this discussion
i kind of thought you know there
wouldn't be any point in talking about
any other
issue i will run into a lot of issues
other than
the election because it is such a
major significant
development as i think pretty much
everybody around the world knows
at this time uh joe biden has won the
election
um there's still counting going on
believe it or not in some places
we talk about why that is actually
the case um there's a whole bunch
there's a whole bunch of stories that
can be told about that
um and you know there's still some
diehards who are saying no no that's
that's not the case wait until all the
lawsuits are done but for the most
part it's it's been called and we can
say that
there is going to be hopefully a fairly
peaceful transition
of power um you know i there there were
some
some craziness in in moving from one
admission
administration to the other in the past
hopefully
that sort of stuff will be avoided um
and you know this has been quite a
important and momentous election so i'm
going to talk about a few things that i
think are
worth bringing up and then i'm going to
take uh
questions and and comments from
everybody and uh
see what we can do with them i think i
might adjust this screen
there a little bit and uh maybe see
i can't fix this there we go that's
that's a little bit better as far as
lighting goes
um so the election is for all intents
and purposes
finished and you know it's taken
not quite a week but um a good part of a
week to get
get full results and because of the
technology
and the means that we're using
especially the heavy reliance
on on mail and ballots um on all sorts
of
you know modes of sorting and counting
it took quite a bit longer in in many
places and there have been some
challenges and there have been a number
of
lawsuits filed most of them seem to be
almost entirely without merit many of
them have been thrown out already
it looks as if even if any of the ones
that have
merit go forward there's really not much
of a chance
of anything being being overturned as
far as the
vote count so so we've got something
that's a
reliable result we can say and you know
it's a major
issue we're talking about the entire
executive branch
which um has been under a very unusual
regime
as we'll talk about in a bit you know
not even really comparable to other
recent republican regimes in in terms of
the extremely high turnover the chaos
caused by it the level of
constant scandals and agitation and
stuff like that
so you know people are talking about
this as a return to
normalcy we'll get into that issue i'm
pretty sure
i don't think there actually is any real
return to a normal
after what's been going on but
we can say that there is there is a
um resolution right and there's still
some runoffs that
have to occur for various legislative
seats
um so not everything is completely
finished with the election cycle
and we can say that neither side i mean
in one respect you can say both sides
had a great turnout right
that's that's kind of nice um and it did
promote a lot of
uh interest in the political system
and participation more than usual
um and and that's in general a good
thing
neither side can be said to have a
mandate um trump definitely didn't have
a mandate
for his administration um it doesn't
look like we can say that the biden
administration has a mandate
either but i don't think that we
actually need mandates
um it's you know in this this point in
time
governance is is probably more important
and you know as with previous elections
the losing side he has some choices in
front of them do they want to
contest things do they want to say well
we lost
this time we need to actually do some
real reflection on why we
lost as we saw the republicans trying to
do
somewhat during the obama years that
they picked the wrong answers of course
with going down the tea party route and
the democrats try to do that during the
bush years as well
or do they simply you know you know
stick to their guns and reinforce their
message and try to obstruct as much as
possible well those are
things that we don't really know we'll
see what what happens
and one thing to keep in mind is that
so here i'm going to say something about
the american
political system and our economic system
and legislative system and all that sort
of stuff
and i'm saying this primarily for the
non-americans out there
who think that things are a little bit
simpler than they are but i'm also
saying this for a lot of americans
because i think a lot of americans have
very oversimplistic conceptions of these
these sorts of things
it doesn't matter um how much you win
the popular vote that's another thing
it's
bragging rights but it doesn't get you
elected
and you know a state isn't red or blue
uh in a real sense they're all mosaics
they're all fragments
milwaukee right here is a pretty blue
thing you get around the rings
of the the three main counties around
us and they're all pretty hard read
except in certain places
and so when we generalize about you know
for example i'll give you a prime
example
somebody um came up with you know this
i'm going to go on a road
trip to celebrate and they like only
went through blue states and then
somebody else pointed out on their their
map you think that a state that
went 49 for biden and
51 for trump is fundamentally different
than a state that went
you know the opposite no these things
are very very complicated
a lot of people don't understand how
much of politics here
in america is local in the sense of
depending on particular
states and how every single state is a
different animal
from the next state over um so
you've got to take cognizance of that
you know looking at you know
a big number like well who got more
popular vote well that's nice
right but it's not really that relevant
you get you got to get as we say a bit
more granular
and that's part of why it's so hard to
change things here in america i've
talked about this in the past with with
respect to policing
with respect to um education with
respect to
health care things are not run just on a
federal level
the you know once we actually have an
administration that's that's you know a
little bit more competent in charge
and we restore the civil service to not
being you know so much
patronage but more professional that's
going to help out but it's not going to
help out that much
it you know the federal government can
do some things on a big scale
a lot of other things are up to the
states they're up to the cities they're
up to the counties
and so this is not going to produce
dramatic change
even if biden had had a reagan style
against
mondale in 84 electoral victory
it still wouldn't change everything the
way that a lot of people are are
thinking that it should
so that's uh you know something to
really keep in mind
we do have a very deeply fractured
nation and it's deeply fractured not
just along state lines like blue states
versus red states it's fractured within
those states it's fractured within
institutions it's fractured within
cities
and one has to be attentive to these
these fault lines i think
going forward um and
you know try to avoid making sweeping
assumptions that just because somebody's
from this county they're automatically
you know supporting the republicans
because somebody's going to this
university they're automatically
supporting the democrats
um so that that's one thing i wanted to
say
another uh thing that that i want to
sort of put out there
is we have some really significant
problems as a nation
that we have to face and
i'm not going to be you know calling for
some sort of illusory
unity uh that we all have to somehow get
on the same page i'm just going to say
if we don't
we're screwed um and and some of this
has to do with things that are bigger
than
than the united states like of course
the environmental
uh issues that you know i mean some
people might say oh climate change not
really happening
you can just look outside here in
wisconsin and see that it has happened
you know and species are moving in it's
you know we were able to walk around
and take a nice stroll today just
wearing you know flannels
when normally we'd have snow falling by
this time when i was a kid
and you know the smart money uh the the
military
the rand corporation all all these
insurance companies
they know that climate change is
happening and so we have to figure out
what we're going to do
you know what we can do and having a
bunch of deniers
as your dialogue partners and having a
bunch of democrats
who are very often in the pocket of
corporate interest is not going to be
conducive to that we also need to change
things when it comes to you know clear
inequities
in policing in education and health care
we have some major problems and these
are not going to go away
and they're not going to be resolved by
returning to some idyllic time that
never existed
before people were you know getting woke
or agitating or anything like that we've
we've got to deal with these problems if
we don't then we
become a failed state we go back to
uh you know the the back of the line at
where
we've been heading for for quite some
time uh not just in the trump
administration but also under the bush
and obama administrations
on many measures if we can't
find some way to work these things out
politically and that's an open question
we are going to be screwed so
we're going to have to figure out how to
deal with those we're also going to have
to figure out what to do
with an economy where i think we can
expect to see
many people unable to find work unable
to find
sufficiently remunerative work
because of all the developments of ai
and logistics and automation
which are not going to stop right now
those are those may be problems that are
worse in some other countries but those
are some
significant issues that we have to face
we can't just you know send everybody to
college
and then you know that'll be the
pipeline to jobs
afterwards we we have to do some serious
thinking and
our current political leadership um
biden uh and harris included but the
trump administration
like if biden and harris are problematic
in that respect the trump administration
was just a bunch of
loonies with res in those those matters
so i don't know where we go in dealing
with those
significant like major uh
scale political issues i don't know if
our system can handle it
somebody's mentioned the electoral
college i also wanted to talk about the
electoral college because a lot of
foreigners and a lot of americans say
we should get rid of this thing and
you're right we should
it's a stupid system it's awful you know
it it gives all the these stupid
priorities
to things that the states that shouldn't
have them
here's the problem it would take a
constitutional amendment
to get rid of it and
that ain't gonna happen if you think
that it's difficult to get
normal legislation passed in this
hyper-partisan climate
do you think you're really gonna be able
to have like a a constitutional
convention
and get entire states to to agree
to this super majority required to
change the constitution
it just won't happen you know the
american constitution
i've said this before in the past but
i'm going to use this metaphor again
the american constitution when it was
first developed was
was not bad you know it was pretty good
as a matter of fact a lot of places
looked at us and they're like oh yeah
this
we should do something like this as well
and
so we got in on the game very early on
and it's sort of like building you know
a nice automobile back around 1920.
it's great for 1920 and if you're into
classic cars
that's that's awesome you know but you
can't take it on the interstate
you can't take it on any real highway
and it's constantly needing repair that
it's not getting
and at a certain point you've got to
realize that the newer models
are way way better in so many other
measures than the one that you've got
but imagine now that you can't change
your car
once you've got it you're stuck with it
and you're never going to be able to get
away
with uh with with changing it you can
like
click you know put a new paint job on it
if you want you can add some fins
you can you can you know make a few new
parts or something like that but you're
basically stuck with a
1920s engine and transmission
and suspension and brakes and all these
things even maybe the radio is not so
good right
it's like a radio with a tape deck an
8-track
tape deck instead of a cd player or
anything else right
well that's our constitution and we're
kind of stuck with it and so
in in many respects because of the
hyper-partisan
uh climate that we're in we're screwed
that's another one of those things where
we really would need to to fix things up
i do also want to talk about two other
things before i start
addressing some of these questions and
comments
one of these is the problem of
having essentially a political party
the republican party one of our main
parties that has been that's
really taken over by by some some key
themes that are in in the in the long
run
and in an ethical point of view quite
quite bad
you know um i understand that a lot of
people are very passionate about you
know second amendment rights
we have a major problem with gun
violence
and the access to firearms and uh you
know
that they stand in the way of that all
the time um
mitt romney is a prime example of
somebody he he tweeted
today that now you know the election's
over he voted uh i think he voted for
biden because you know trump is such
just a hot mess right and went after
romney
personally all these times and then he
said now
we're going to make sure that there is
no medicare for all there is no
you know moving things forward on the
environment you know essentially it's
just an obstructionist platform
we're gonna do everything we can to try
to keep things backwards
and you know resist any sort of progress
um that's the republican party add in
some some heavy doses of racism
and an individualistic conception of
freedom that says
screw my neighbor covered denial
and um you know now q anon you know
as sort of a cancer metastasizing within
all these ranks and you've got some
pretty pretty
uh problematic stuff so the republicans
i mean i'm an independent
so i am pretty critical of both parties
i
vote strategically against who i think
is the worst evil or who has the better
prospects for things i voted for
republicans in the past
the republican party of today it's
just a mess and they know that the only
way that they can hold on to power
is through voters depression and through
gerrymandering and all these things that
are anti-democratic you know
that's a really bad sign also by
appealing to the worst
instincts of people the democrat party's
got a lot of problems too
you know beholden to many corporations
and corporate interests biden has a
long-standing you know connection to the
banking industry
we have some serious issues with debt
that we need to resolve
and but but here's the thing we can
actually push the democrats and
say you know you need to do the right
thing on these things and that's that's
what i plan to be doing
in the next uh years is spending a good
bit of time doing
advocacy um for the things that i think
that need to be
fixed and doing a lot of local
organizing and and working with
organizations
and um so you know there's there's this
issue
of of one party essentially having like
gone off a crazy cliff
and then the other party being er it's
okay but it's it's not great what do we
do
well we're stuck with them and so we've
got to work with that
i think that in some cases you have to
cordon off
the crazy and refuse to cooperate with
them
uh our our local you know republicans
here in wisconsin are a prime example of
pretty crazy stuff
you know you look at our supreme court
and uh the decision that that
invalidated the governor's math mandate
one of the justices was talking about it
being tyranny and you're like
man these people are nuts we still have
to
find ways to work with them so that
brings me to the last topic that i want
to talk about i see all these calls for
like
empathy and reconciliation
you know trumpies um and their
supporters who just you know
a few days ago were rallying two blocks
from here
um oh you know they they just didn't
understand what they were getting into
and
it's not going to do any good to be mean
to them and say mean things to them
and you know my attitude first of all as
a democrat
you know i'm not a democrat so if i was
a democrat i'd be saying
well screw you because you did the same
thing when you were in charge so now
we're going to do the same thing
as an independent i'm you know like
wow you know i don't owe anybody
anything i certainly don't owe anybody
any empathy
and if i'm going to give empathy it's
going to be to the victims of the trump
regime
it's definitely not going to be to
anybody who supported the trump regime
because the only way you get empathy
after supporting somebody like trump is
by saying
holy crap was i wrong
i need to do things to fix this if they
want to do that then i'll entertain
conversations with them about
how they can make themselves into better
people
but man until they do that forget it
and all these people out there lecturing
about oh you don't want to be as bad as
them
we don't have to worry about that they
were really really bad they
still are really really bad a lot of
them are still you know
hardcore racists applauding you know uh
all sorts of things to suppress people's
votes you know applauding
excessive police violence
there's no reason why we have to feel
bad for them or anything like that
they can go sort out their their hurt
feelings on their own
and some people are saying oh well
you're preparing for a trump victory in
2024
trump probably is is not going to be
around even in 2024
because i mean look at the health that
he's in even put that aside
um enough people have seen through his
bs at this point
you know the the the pin pricked the
balloon
he's not going to be around you could
say well there might be another person
like that
yeah we can make all sorts of
predictions um
i think that a lot of this this call for
empathy and reconciliation
is very um
you know it's it's very self-serving
it's people who really
like that sort of thing maybe even have
a stake in coaching people how to do it
um that that want to push that
the peacemakers right you shouldn't
always make peace
and and we also have to keep this in
perspective calling somebody
an [ __ ] on twitter is not like
burning their house down
it's not knocking the food out of their
children's mouths or anything like that
you know
so this touchiness on the part of
conservative snowflakes
and liberal snowflakes who don't want
anyone to criticize the
the trump uh regime or its followers or
anything like that
it's really quite silly and so you know
they can live up to the same standards
as
anybody else if you screw up if you
break things you fix them then you get
to apologize and then it's up to the
other person
to say whether they want to go along
with you or not
the last thing i'll actually say too is
that
i think the democrats there's a lot of
discussion about what should
the democrats be doing should they have
a more you know progressive message
um should they try to be centrist i'll
say this is an independent right so
somebody who is in the middle
i want to see the democrats actually
being progressive i i i want to see an
alternative this is one part of why
clinton lost you know there are a number
of reasons why she lost but
the party when it's an establishment
thing it's not really putting forth a
new alternative
to the republicans and it's not usually
doing what's what's right i mean
universal health care
is the way to go that that would be the
right thing to do
i don't care who puts it in place if the
republicans put it in place i'll applaud
them for doing that
unfortunately they're too nuts right now
to even consider that because that would
be socialism you know
um if the democrats do it independents
like me would be for that
you know i'm not on the left but i would
like to see the left play a much bigger
role
in the democratic party and they can
count on people like me
voting that way in swing states like
wisconsin
so when democrats say oh if we're not
pushing you know more to the center and
like
getting in good with these republicans
we're going to lose votes
that's true in some counties that's not
true everywhere and that's not true of
all constituencies
all right so a lot of stuff here that
people been writing
let me start taking some of these
questions barklord
says are there effective ways to get
older relatives to examine their fusion
of christianity patriotism right
libertarianism and white supremacist
racism
it's kind of a case-by-case thing there
are some people who are so far off in
nutty land that they're never coming
back
and you know it could have been
something else they could have been
nutty about some
fandom they could have been nutty
selling stuff for amway
but they happen to have like shifted
into this
some you can reach and the way that you
reach them is by maintaining contacts
and by being firm
in where you actually stand not saying
oh
well you know i'll just keep everything
under
wraps you know you treat them like you
would anybody
anybody else and if they want to say
stuff that's [ __ ]
and uh you know you think it's [ __ ]
you can tell them that it's [ __ ]
and and you know you can do that nice
ways and you can do that
in mean ways right um and you can also
preface it with i love you because
you're in my family but i think you're
dead wrong about this stuff
and so many people will you know will
come back from the brink
that way i think you know so many of us
every once in a while need somebody to
come along and say wow you really are
acting like an [ __ ]
and you don't have any good reason for
it and this
i'm not happy to see this you know
people need messages
like that rather than just being treated
with kid gloves
um and and it it shouldn't go into i
mean if they get upset about this
well sorry you're upset i'll see you
next saturday you know
next time we have uh some family
get-together or something like that but
i'm not gonna hang around and listen to
this
i think that's in many respects that's
the way to go but there might be some
relatives who you got to be
you know uh more standoffish with and
there's some relatives where you could
do like socratic questioning
although usually people get pretty
pissed off when you would
use the credit questioning it's part of
why they killed socrates
um but i think that you you you keep
engaged
i don't think that there's any moral
obligation
to like continue conversations past
points where it's clearly useless
that doesn't mean you can't have further
conversations down the line
but you know if somebody's
it really depends on how far how far
down they've gone um
and you know with the christianity thing
you you know the great thing about
christianity is there's things called
the gospels where jesus actually
preached things like
you know taking care of the poor and you
can bring up those quotes or you know
you could like
bring up thomas aquinas's favorite quote
from isaiah
what are those who call good evil evil
good darkness light
you know light darkness bitter sweet and
sweet bitter
and say well what do you think about
this how you doing with the sermon on
the mount grandpa you know
um and you know they may get
get all ticked but at a certain point
enough of that pressure can get them to
say
wow i really am acting in an
anti-christian way
what's going on with me how did i slide
down this this
shoot into thinking that like you know
flying a blue lives matter
uh flag could somehow be an example of
christianity when it's really the
opposite
so that might be a way to do it um
patriotism you know you could talk about
people who are actual patriots
like you know all the soldiers who
enforce the disarming of of
you know dixie you could say during
reconstruction they were patriots
um people they fought against definitely
weren't
and um you know there's ways in which
you can like turn their stuff on its
head but
you know you gotta do a bit of work with
that
j crass i wouldn't say the democrats won
by a large enough margin it's not a good
sign
that's good enough you know it's what it
is
um you know any anything could be
better in some ideal universe but we
have to do politics where we are i'd say
uh jasmine hamilton has a question about
locke's moral philosophy we're not
that's not what we're doing here this
isn't an ama this is a political theory
uh and practice discussion um
all right mark mark says the electoral
college is a weird thing
yeah almost everywhere they have better
systems
for deciding things then this this
stupid crazy electoral college but as i
mentioned
we're really stuck with it there's no
way effectively to get rid of it
and so we have to work within its
confines i'll say another thing too that
that's
you know there's two other things that i
see
in other countries that i really wish we
had here
one is many countries do not allow
electoral campaigns um beyond a certain
point
in time so it could be like you can do
you know eight weeks
out from the election and that's it you
can't start doing all sorts of political
action committees and campaigning and
doing all this stuff
a year before i think it's really bad
for us that we're in a perpetual
election cycle
much of the time that that's part of
what leads to this massive polarization
it's not to say that people couldn't
talk politics outside of that time but i
think that there shouldn't be
you know i think we need we need well
we're not going to get it but
ideally we would get a system where um
you don't get to start campaigning
basically once you've been elected
it's really bad too for the house of
representatives because their terms are
every two years so they
are like on every election cycle the
other thing is you know there are some
places where
we americans make it very difficult in
some places for
certain people to vote right usually
happens to minorities
and poor people that we we make it hard
for them to vote
i would love to see uh voting be
required
you know and you pay a fine if you don't
vote like in some countries but
we don't have that so uh hairy tall boys
the problem is america is so big it's
almost like trying to run a continent
rather than a country
i guess i mean you could say similar
things about
um russia china india
to a certain extent brazil um
you know i mean canada is
pretty large they don't have as big of a
population
but they they they certainly have their
their challenges
i i don't know that it's it's um
[Music]
i don't know that it's really about the
trying to run a continent
there there is there are some
significant differences between
regions in america um
and how things are done and how things
are understood but at the same time
uh there's also sort of a broad culture
that's
that's shared as well so
yeah that's that's i'd have to think
more about that
all right um
skip says path to a failed state since
about the mid 90s for sure
yeah you know um some of this goes back
even further the
you know the you might say all
in on globalization and the loss of our
industrial base
that's a significant problem in part
because not just of
of you know losing track of where things
are being built and having these
incredibly long supply chains
but also because of what it did to um
wages and things like that yeah the 90s
were a deceptive
you know so i'll say something that i
was saying to somebody else
in a conversation earlier this week um
the 1990s as far as i remember them and
you know i was a college student back
then
they were a time when
the idea seemed to be and this is what
third wave democrats
were all about um they kept saying
it's the economy stupid you grow the
economy and
you're making a bigger pie and so even
if you don't
solve like the inequities within the pie
you're getting a bigger pie so
everybody's doing better overall
right which is not the same thing as
like trickle-down economics which is
what
reagan was all about where you make
people richer on top and then they will
create jobs and all that which turned
out to be complete
complete nonsense that that that doesn't
um but neither do you grow the my thing
because the iniquities are still there
and then when
pi shrinks again like it did in the
2000s
uh a number of times then people are
more
ticked off because they can see that the
inequities have been there and
and just get perpetuated and sometimes
they're even they're even worse it's
a more unequal share of the pie you know
you look at
um ages compared to
wage growth compared to what what the
top one percent or the top 10 percent
are
earning um so yeah there's there's some
real issues the failed state thing i
mean we're not at the point yet
where we have um
militias going but the fact that we had
people try to kidnap the michigan
governor
and um people trying to
affect the vote count in philly driving
up with with uh
rifles right and that we have all these
these uh people coming to marches
and protests with guns
that shouldn't be the case at all that's
a really bad sign
that that is a sign of moving towards a
failed state
um we have a we have a lot of
indices where i mean medically too i
mean
our health care system is just it's not
a it's not a system it's actually a
whole bunch of interlocking
systems that connect with each other
most of which don't work particularly
well for most people
so we've got some serious issues to deal
with
uh morgan says how do you deal with
family members who've joined the mag
occult i'm thinking of cutting them off
in my life
they live in a different dimension i
think it's perfectly fine to
to do that um you know and you don't
necessarily have to like
give them a big fu before you cut them
out you can just like
de-emphasize you could say you could be
like listen i'm not
i'm not going to spend time with you and
if they want to ask why you can say
i don't want to hear your rhetoric you
know i don't see eye to eye with you on
really basic values
that's okay to do if you want to keep
engaged with them that's also
okay to do you know both of those i
think are
are legitimate i think that this is a
big problem that that is running down
the middle of many
many families particularly many extended
families
it's also affecting workplaces it's also
affecting
uh you know colleges and universities
um but it's not as if you owe them
anything it would be as if they had
decided to join
some other cult you know
except in this case there aren't there
aren't really a lot of deprogrammers
right because they don't recognize that
they're in a cult
um jasmine says found some of your
videos on divine law and natural law
with thomas aquinas they're helpful well
that's good
um xenocryst says
i hear you morgan thanksgiving this year
is going to be awkward
well you know um i mean we're not going
to be with anybody for thanksgiving
ourselves
because of kovid i think that's another
thing too you know the
whether or not you take kovid seriously
or of you wearing a mask and social
distancing is tyranny against your
liberty or something like that
that's that's one of those dividing
lines and i think it's perfectly fine to
say listen
um you don't you don't actually like
take coven seriously we're not coming to
your household we're in the middle of a
pandemic still
that has not gone away you know um
thanks alex that's very very nice of you
uh
let's see what we have um
craig says it's the increasing pace of
change that forces us into separate
camps some love it some
hate it yeah that's part of it
um i mean whether you're whether or not
you think that that say racial
equity issues should be resolved is
another thing that's really separating
us or whether you think policing
needs to be brought under some sort
of control so that all these supposed
bad apples can be gotten rid of that
that's another big dividing issue you
know
um brenda asked do you agree with some
that the hard left hurt the democrats i
take hard left to mean marxist leninist
i mean there's not many marxist
leninists out there there's a lot
more people on the left than there are
actual devoted marxist leninists
i mean this is one of these this is a
good a good question because this is one
of these things where what i was saying
about
um you got to look at these things
granularly
there are places where being identified
with say
defund the police or you know working
for
uh uh you know ending racism
or any of these sorts of things that are
viewed as you know almost
both socialist and utopian you know
where it could hurt you right
there's a lot of places where the people
who
ran on were not that way they lost and
maybe a more progressive candidate would
have won
i know that i'm gonna vote for if if it
aligns with what i think as a virtue
ethicist
uh needs to happen as somebody who's
like looking at the long term
um i'm gonna vote for for people who put
it who are actually going to a spouse
and probably work for the kind of
policies that i think are
are important so you know universal
health care
if you're for that then i'm going to
vote for you as an independent
as somebody who's pretty middle of the
road rather than voting for somebody
who's just republican light the way that
that many of the people were on offer
but i'm here in a swing state of
wisconsin where
you know it's sort of like anything goes
um if i was in tennessee
maybe not you know so i i don't think
that
you can say that the the left um
espousing policies of the left uh
hurt or helped democrats per se i think
what you can say
is that there's two things that you can
say one is that now that biden
is in office so under abide in regime um
anybody who's on the left ought to be
pushing super hard
to get some of these things enacted
you're not going to get everything
but you can certainly say hey reconsider
medicare for all
you know i'm cool with repeating that
message every day to biden because i
think that's that's
an important uh policy um
the other thing about the uh left right
thing
so people have pointed out that uh
part of what drove the voting is the
organizing on the part of people on the
left
to deliver votes for the biden harris
campaign
and that will often be taken for granted
just as as
often times the african-american vote is
you know
it's relied upon and then taken for
granted and and they have to push too
you know actually that was great the
celebration that was out in the park
yesterday that's exactly what the
message was
you know fortunately we won now we gotta
organize
now we gotta like um keep pushing hard
to get these these
center not even center left just center
democrats to deliver on what they ought
to do so
that's a good question hey bruce
good to see you here as well um
all right uh let me pick up another
question here um
guttergrown says i hope trump isn't
going to try to intimidate the electoral
college votes so you mean the electors
themselves
you know i think trump is is basically
done
um i think he was he he's like
a lot of other blowhards and bullies um
he's he's gotten a really rough you know
bop on the nose and he's going to go off
and sulk and and whine and complain
he'll
you know he'll be on tv and and he'll
try to
do things but now he has to actually
worry about prosecution and
investigations right so he's also
probably like
literally you know crapping a brick at
this point in time
i don't i don't think he's going to try
to do anything really
all right uh jason
says it seems like in the earlier part
of the 20th century the distribution
between liberal and conservative
academics is more even than it is now
any theory white is so skewed lib now
it's not really skewed lib
it's uh it's all over the map it depends
on what college you're at i mean this is
one of the bugaboos of
of uh uh of the right they love to say
oh
you know college uh you know and then
they have this like monolithic thing
that they think college is
you gotta you gotta like i mean spend
some time in a non-elite college or
something that's not on the the east
coast or the west coast
here in the midwest you're gonna find a
wide range
of of college professors and you know
it also depends on what college you're
looking at go to a business or economics
school
within a university or an engineering
school
you are going to find a lot of
conservatives there you're even going to
find a lot of people
reading and talking about ein rand um
going to humanities departments maybe
less so
right but you're still going to find a
pretty good distribution
so you know the other thing is to
um i would say that that you know
there's
there's uh there's some conservatives
that just aren't gonna entertain going
to college
right um and so there's a there's a
proportion of that
i i don't think looking at our current
crop of college students and i teach in
a number of different places
that they're particularly leftist
um either when they come in or when they
go out
it depends again on the institution
milwaukee institute of art and design
school of designers and artists much
more liberal
than milwaukee area technical college
than
marquette university you know or vice
versa
all right um lokisha says
lokesh sorry says i think trumpism is
more than a cult
shares us a lot of characteristics but
what it specifically does is blur the
line between religion and the state it's
the shaping of a new political identity
yeah kind of i mean i would call it a
proto-fascism i mean it is
as somebody who researches far-right
movements um
starting with like oxygen francaise and
integral nationalism and then
fascism national socialism all that sort
of stuff
it's pretty you know the writing is
pretty clear in the way that they've
behaved and the things that they've
they've done
and the rhetoric that they've used
they're within that spectrum
um i don't think it's going to survive
all that long it'll probably metastasize
into something
something else down the line you know
all right mike remington why are you
guys cutting family out of your life
over some political ideology left and
right are not that far apart on things
i'd say that's wrong left and right are
pretty far apart on things
and and i would say that you know the
republican party in the democratic party
on
important uh measures are
quite a bit different from each other
perhaps
more than they were 20 years ago
and i think it's perfectly fine i mean
you could cut family out of your life
for
for other reasons i mean you can always
go back to them it's not like you're you
know
cutting a bridge and destroying it
forever right i mean you would do so
with people who are
abusers you you can do so with people
who don't cope with their addictions
properly
um you know sometimes that's what you
have to do
craig says guns lead to arguments which
lead to guns
um yeah that's that's a problem uh
there is there's a cycle there all right
um
xenocrat says in some families that's
true europe thinks we have two
conservative parties one on the right
one further to the right
yeah you know um that is that is quite
true a lot of americans lack
fundamental perspective when talking
about left and right
the democratic party is pretty centrist
you know
um so mason we said you're neither
liberal nor conservative but a virtue
ethicist what does this look like in
practice as a
in politics well i've said it i i look
at policies and i pick the ones that i
think
are actually you know serving some sort
of common good
i think that character counts for
something that was part of why
i very early on had to like say
you know i'll i'll give trump by the
benefit of the doubt
um but he didn't deserve it and neither
did
the the people who he put in power did
neither even like the people who
were supposedly there to check him show
themselves to lack character in the end
like kelly for example
i think that matters i think that we
should be working for
justice i think that we need to look at
the dispositions that we have ourselves
and um uh how we how we engage in
politics because it could be too
easy to get into anger and then have
this end the cycle that's a problem on
both left and right
it can be too easy to become super
anxious about things
i'll tell you this you know if you want
to understand
uh what virtue ethics looks like in
politics and you want to look at it in
terms of
you know old schools or virtual ethics
read aristotle's politics
see what he actually has to say it's a
very nuanced view
he says you know there are going to be
these competing things he he
focuses primarily on the rich
and the many and he says both of them
understand justice in a certain way but
both of them are skewed
and then we need the people who actually
keep society functioning the ari story
the best the good
the people who develop virtues and are
usually like
what the hell is this [ __ ] coming
from these these
two sets of selfish morons who kind of
get some things right
you know aristotle didn't pull any
punches he said that
every one of the currently existing
greek city-states was defective
you know uh or you can look at the
stoics you know they they put forward
a virtue ethics as well and they
participated in politics
you know as best as they they could they
didn't withdraw from it
so it also means being strategic
you know if the democratic party turns
into a bunch of whack jobs tomorrow
i'll all be voting against them you know
i
i was pretty critical
i've been pretty critical of most
administrations
during the course of my lifetime um so
yeah all right uh
let's see what we got here
there's a lot of back and forth i'm
going to jump ahead a little bit
jeff asks a question here any thoughts
on the trade-off between ideals and
pragmatism watching aoc attack the
new entire democratic coalition makes me
worry even if i generally agree with the
progressive policies
i wouldn't say she's actually attacking
i mean i read her twitter stream
i would say there's a difference between
attacking and rightly pointing stuff out
and she's actually like responding to
people saying oh you shouldn't talk
about
defund the police she's like well you
know
those who refuse to talk about that
lost a lot of their seats so i don't if
you want to call that an attack
i guess you can she also pointed out
that a lot of the people who lost
had really crap um ground games
including their their electronics
communication
um and you know it's funny that you
bring up like
idealism or ideals and pragmatism
pragmatists have ideals
pragmatists in the sense of like actual
american pragmatism the
philosophy would say that we
push and we take our ideals and we put
them into practice
and we try to fight for them and
eventually they become realities right
and there's going to be some give and
take
but pragmatism and ideals are not
opposed to each other there it's not
like there's a continuum with pragmatism
on one end what you mean is expediency
what you mean
is uh what they call the the um
the useful or the expedient rather than
the pragmatic because
pragmatism always presumes that we have
some some like substantive goals in mind
otherwise this is kind of an unmoored
sort of like listening to wherever the
wind is blowing and going that way
um all right let's see here
mike says you're lumping whole groups as
if they're a single borg like my name
calling really come on man maybe take
people as individuals and not worry
about what they say
so that's totally unrealistic when we're
talking about politics
especially in a nation of over 300
million people we are going to not just
like talk about each little individual
and we are going to talk about
categories the question is whether we're
accurate or whether we're off base when
we're doing that
so you know it's very usually when
people bring that up they're being
very selective because nobody get nobody
doesn't do that
right nobody treats every single person
as an individual
and if you want to think of it as name
calling well maybe this
maybe this isn't for you you know um i i
don't have a problem calling a spade a
spade or a crazy a crazy
and um we've had four years of a
thoroughly nutty corrupt degenerate
uh in you know regime in place
that just brought a lot of chaos and
worsened outcomes for people in so many
different ways
indulged in cruelty you want to think of
that as name calling
that's your choice um i would call it
being
being accurate about our political
situation but that's that's you know
that's life
all right um force convalescence
beaten used china used china to
interfere with the election
so there's no grounds for for that and
that's really
ridiculous i'm going to
uh put that one into a timeout
all right uh carter love the
constitution car analogy
just curious who did you like in the
democratic primaries oh okay i actually
voted for
um sanders um in part because he was the
the candidate who was actually pushing
forth the things that i thought needed
to be addressed i didn't have super high
hopes
for for what what he was going to
accomplish and it turned out that the
democratic party
as a whole really you know did him in
um which which angered whoa did that
anger a lot of people who were
were for the first time quite um
quite uh enthusiastic about
politics um you know and it's the second
time around would a sanders
administration have been perfect
no um i think there would have been some
issues where
now from a more conservative point of
view i would have had to say hey pump
the brakes on that buddy right
but i think that it would have been
going more in the right direction
on a number of different things um
so yeah but i mean here's something i
can say
i live in wisconsin and so by the time
that we get to primaries here in
wisconsin
the fix is kind of in you know there's
not much that we're in
april so super tuesday's happened all
these other things have happened
we don't really get much say this is
part of the problem with with the
the processes we have it set up right
now you know there are so many ways
in which our system if you want to call
it that is
is militates against any real democracy
you know and by democracy i don't just
mean everybody votes or mob rule or
something like that
i mean where we have a real substantive
like hashing things out everybody's
voices getting heard in some
some respect and being addressed
you know we just don't have that there's
so many ways in which our
our system is is uh flawed in that way
all right uh lorenzo says the democratic
coalition the younger progressives are
attacking
are the people who let trump come to
power
the democratic coalition uh yeah i guess
to some degree i mean
putting forth so going back four years
right
clinton was a terrible candidate um the
idea that somehow she deserved to be in
place
and the sidelining of sanders
and really anything that he had to say
um and the lack of any other
alternatives and bringing in
all these democratic insiders who are
essentially just elites and
don't don't really care about the
ordinary person you know
um that turned people off
that opened the door for trump and so
you know picking
another group like that like here's a
great example i'm emanuel who is you
know
uh secretary under under obama shouldn't
have been in there
right um brought
brought in basically as a clinton
insider um
and then you know he was mayor of
chicago for a while he's just a garbage
person
all across the board he's a terrible uh
person
he he should have been kicked at the
democratic party a long time ago but
he's got juice he's got connections
and he's still spouting nonsense on
twitter you know uh nobody should listen
to him
but that's the kind of person who they
they brought in or donna brazile
or uh now i'm blanking on her name she
was the party chairperson for a while
uh also instrumental so yeah people like
that
open the door the democrats have to be
the better party
right if the republicans aren't going to
be
um to be the party not for
their elites not just for their donors
but for ordinary people
um craig brings up an old
saying they say you haven't got a heart
you haven't got a heart if not liberal
when you're young and you haven't got
head when you're not conservative when
you're old
um i mean
people do become more conservative when
they have more of a stake in the system
do older people who are finding that
health care is bankrupting them
and wind up having to come out of
retirement to work at walmart
are they do they have a stake in the
system or are they are they screwed by
the system
you know that that's a good question to
ask about that i think that that saying
presumes a certain kind of continuity of
life
that isn't there um
let's see here
jason uh says isn't that synonymous with
saying well we can afford to be a bit
bad because they're really bad
there is a degree of moral equivalency
in that argument and that's a tough pill
to swallow
well it's it's not a degree of moral
equivalency you either have moral
equivalency or you don't
so it's not it's not a degree thing and
no
it's putting things in proportion um i
mean unless you expect people to be
saints
which they're not and you shouldn't um
we're gonna deal with better and worse
that's
that's a fundamental part of ethics
right it's not just about the good or
the bad it's about the better or the
worse
and you know this is this is like all
the way going back aristotle and the
stoics and cicero
and all these great thinkers so uh
no i i think and and if you want to call
like saying that that we shouldn't
extend an olive branch to trumpers who
have no interest in cooperating with
anybody
is something bad i guess we differ on
that so
yeah um
let's see i'm gonna drop down a bit
there's some back
and forth here
mariana says four years are not as scary
with trump when we realize biden should
be taken care of instead of being
paraded
yeah that's that's just kind of silly um
i think biden is is is doing fine all
right um
morgan says bernie shouldn't have called
himself a democratic socialist who is
actually a moderate and pushed for
policies found in other countries
you know that might that might be i mean
if he didn't call himself a socialist
everyone would be
uh i don't know that that you can really
repackage what he's doing
here in the american you're right here
in the american
system we are pretty far
right as far as like what you know
rational policies
would be and the things that we can we
can uh accept all right it's skipped
down a bit so i gotta see where we are
um
a lot of back and forth discussion here
um
somebody says did you even know the
meaning of fascism buddy i've written
articles on it so
yeah i kind of do um
people want to try to debate that you
know good luck to you
um
let's see here
where are we oh aaron says thanks for
your hard work especially for
sharply and clearly articulating these
nuances uh
thanks very much um i'm glad that you
like that
all right uh wow there's a lot of
back and forth stuff here um
fatal remains says uh what makes
something occult isn't its political
stance
it can be actually there's a wide range
of things that are cults
also trump's mishandling of china's
stupid tariff wars only allowed china to
gain in strength and influence
yeah he when it comes to foreign policy
the trump administration was was really
a hot mess
um and and uh
the chinese have been pretty happy with
with you know what what trump is doing
um they they come at i mean they have
some weaknesses
in their system as well that have to be
dealt with before too long
but um they're coming at things from a
position of strength trump's tariffs
really
decimated uh people here in in various
industries in the midwest i'll say too
so um
all right let's see
ergonomic says biden is bush 2.0 no way
marxist leninist get anything they
wanted
um yeah i don't know that biden is bush
2.0 i think that's kind of a silly thing
to say
there are some some differences but
there are there's a lot of continuity
between
between them um
alex says kovid will be the excuse for
awkward family holidays
yeah that's that's quite true um
after ref says people voted for biden
because he isn't trump it was sufficient
to get him elected so i don't think the
left will get anything they want
it depends on how much the left pushes
you know um
you got to really avoid these over
simplistic the left is going to get what
they want or they're not going to get
what they want
it's going to be a package you know
where you get like a bit of this and
then you don't get this
and a bit of this and don't get this and
it's going to depend how much people
mobilize and how much people fight for
these these sorts of things
renzo says the west has a long history
of installing dictatorships to keep
their economic relationships that's fine
but that doesn't really have much to do
with this election
um
all right there's a lot of back and
forth about totalitarian regimes that
i'm gonna i'm gonna skip
over uh mariana says if you go to mit
you'll find epstein's buddies apparently
uh sure so what um
a lot of those epstein's buddies were
hanging out with the republicans who
were the ones who gave him an easy deal
right um people are crappy all over the
place right
is that is that the basic idea barklord
my philosophy teacher in community
college is an
iron rand fan i had a colleague at
marist who is a iran scholar
you know they're out there there's quite
a few of them
uh all right let's see if we can find
our way to something kind of substantive
um
okay here's a good question rishi how do
you think the biden administration will
work around the republican senate it's
nice that biden won but it feels like
like without the senate it almost feels
like a symbolic victory to me
well if you think that it's only a
symbolic victory then you underrate what
can be done through the executive agency
um you know reagan had to go
with a democratic senate right you often
have these split things
so it means that you have to push forth
an agenda biden was in the senate he
knows a lot of these people he can
probably
you know it's funny because trump was
like i'm an outsider i'm going to fix
all this stuff
sometimes you actually need an insider
who can who can engage in that sort of
sort of
wheeling and dealing it's likely that
mitch mcconnell
uh so long as the republicans retain
control of the senate is
just going to engage in as much
obstruction as possible but that's going
to be damaging to them in 2022.
you know we're going to try to vote out
ron johnson here in wisconsin
he's up for election in 2022 and he has
he's on record is you know saying a lot
of dumb stuff and
engaging in a lot of obstructions so
he's pretty vulnerable
um you'll often see in my twitter stream
you know the hashtag votronout2022
because we're going to remember
right so but you can do so much with
executive orders you can do so much by
what you
fund what you don't fund you can do so
much by how
things work in the various departments
whether education i mean think about
just getting rid of betsy devos
you know from the department of
education huge
huge difference already right there you
know
she was turning things uh backwards and
actually
not even going back to a screwed up pass
but like trying to make things
as as bad as possible with him within
her
her organization get rid of also the the
sort of like
taking civil service jobs and trying to
turn them essentially into
you know you're with us or against us uh
patronage jobs that the trump
administration was doing
it's there's gonna be a lot of changes
so not controlling the senate is not
is not totally uh neutering
the incoming biden administration um
cody says do you think it's better to
reform the democrats to adopt
progressive policies from within
outside or some mix everything in
politics works better with some
some mix broad spectrum uh things you'll
you'll see
independents like me telling them hey if
you want to keep getting our independent
vote in swing states
you better actually start endorsing some
of these things and i'm not going to be
saying swing left i'm going to be saying
medicare for all i'm going to be saying
overseeing
you know policing you know breaking down
these these old boy blue networks and
stuff like that
i'm going to be saying focus on domestic
terrorists reign in the militias
you know these sorts of things and i'll
be saying it from over here
and the leftist can say it from over
there and other people
can say it from other places and when
you've got a broad base like that people
are often like
oh it's not just this one group that's
saying this we better get our crap
together because because uh
you know we're we're really going to um
get you know our butts handed to us if
we if we don't
uh do that um let's see
my dog is going crazy with all these dog
whistles in chat
yeah that's that's a good point um
let's see here
um
eftereff says do you think the supreme
court will throw out election results
out of loyalty to trump
so that's actually a good point to talk
about the supreme
court can only act on cases that are
brought to them
and interestingly roberts
has been showing signs of
you know he was appointed by bush and
roberts
and alito to a certain extent have been
siding on important cases
with the the liberals on the court in
part because they're like this is enough
[ __ ] from these these people who
don't have no business being here like
kavanaugh you know
um i think they're kind of sick of of of
some of the nonsense and so they're
going to be more of a centrist
uh thing it's not going to go to the
supreme court though i don't think i
mean i could be totally wrong about this
maybe somebody will find
some case that would somehow fix things
but here's the deal you can bring a case
about a particular state
if you flip one of the states does biden
lose and trump win
nope not with the results as we have
them now
so even if you manage to flip
pennsylvania
which is not going to happen um
it still wouldn't i think get get uh
trump the victory that he wants and and
the the cases that the trump lawyers
have been bringing
are so egregiously bad that judges have
been like rolling their eyes
and saying you got to be kidding me
you're taking my time up with this
bs so i don't think it's going to go to
the supreme court
um
all right let's see here
some back and forth ah
some back and forth here about about
racism
zeitgeist says what do you think about
diversity race quotas i think
discriminating on the basis of race is
racist even though it's for non-racist
reasons
it depends on the situation you know um
i think sometimes
uh if the racism has been egregious
enough to like keep people out of
particular positions i don't have a
problem with with opening things up and
saying you're going to hire somebody of
this group
or you're going to hire a woman should
it be a long-term thing probably not i
mean sandra day o'connor you know
reflecting on
on the supreme court case back how long
ago that was like in the bush
administration i believe or maybe it was
in the obama administration was talking
about
equal opportunity in admissions for
colleges and she was like
still need it right now but 20 years
from now we should get rid of it so
i think that's something that we do have
to be you know rather pragmatic about
um x christ said i've always wanted to
get into american pragmatism i admire
dewey a lot
yeah dewey's do he's okay he's not the
most easy writer to read because he's
like hagel he's not a great stylist so
all right um
hank quinnian uh quinlan are you
familiar with leo strauss's assertion
all post enlightenment permissive
liberalism ends in totalitarianism
he suggested aristotle's virtue theory
is an alternative yeah i've read a lot
of leo
strauss i encountered strauss back as a
graduate student i don't take him
seriously or straussian seriously
um and you know he's interesting to read
somebody asked me about
about him yesterday in terms of like
secondary lit
so yeah i'll like read them on on hobbs
and occasionally he'll get some stuff
right
that's worth putting into a paper but i
i don't
i think as a cultural critic strauss is
way off base
so all right um
let's see try to get some stuff from
people that i
i haven't taken some questions from
before
um
some discussion about thomas sowell
somebody else i don't take seriously
having read him as an undergraduate
and back in graduate school i mean he's
sort of second rate um
but if you if you if you're into him
that's that's
fine there's better stuff you could
spend your time on but
all right um let's see here
so jeff asked what do you think needs to
be addressed by the democratic party
universal healthcare universal basic
income
i don't think we're going to see a
universal basic income unfortunately
and a little earlier i was saying we
have some really big problems on the
horizon one of them
is the changing work
labor marketplace right as we have more
and more automation
and ai
and things like that i think we're going
to see pretty high rates of unemployment
and we me we may need to do something
like a universal basic income but i
think the discuss i mean we should talk
about it now but i think the
policy discussions about it are going to
happen long off it's cool that they are
doing
experiments in different places like
finland or canada or even
you know i think there's a few going on
here in the united states where they're
like doing a community and then they
target them with a universal basic
income
and that can be kind of helpful i think
universal healthcare we're going to have
to enact it at some time or another or
we're screwed
you know homelessness one of the main
reasons people are homeless medical debt
people go bankrupt over medical debt
one reason why our covid response has
been so
so awful uh wasn't just the incompetency
of the trump administration and the
denial that a real problem was taking
place it was even if we had a good
administration in place
our health care system which is not a
system but a whole bunch of interlocking
systems much of which is for
profit was just not up to the task
so people weren't getting tested when
they should we're not really doing
contact tracing
and kovit is out of control here and
we've we've had you know
several hundred thousand people die now
at this point who didn't need to
um alex asked what do you know about
terms like democratic modernity
i mean they're vague terms they can mean
anything that you want them to
they always have to be indexed to a
particular group or a theorist
or movement that is using them i would
say
um jason asks
on the electoral college if you could
wave the proverbial magic
wand would you prefer the popular vote
each state going to the nebraska model
or something different
i mean i think i would want to go to
something like a parliamentary system
where you vote for the party
and then the party chooses their their
leader
and i would like to see ranked choice
voting as well
where if you know if or you know having
runoffs or things like that i i
whatever's going to make it more more
participatory more democratic than what
we currently have
and i would say you know something that
has to go along with this is we need way
more accountability
on the part of politicians it's really
easy to say well
you hold them accountable by voting them
out but in our gerrymandered system
it's impossible to vote so many of the
representatives out it's tough to vote
um uh governors out um
you know and and so i think we have to
have way more accountability
all right um oh here's a great one by
cody
how much of an influence does money in
politics affect things will we ever end
many in politics possibly a
constitutional amendment well
to start with there aren't going to be
any constitutional amendments that's
just not going to happen
not in our lifetime not not with things
the way they are um
so unless we have some sort of radical
shift
and a unity government of some sort
we're not going to have a constitutional
amendment
money in politics major problem um you
know citizens united
basically allowed that's a court
decision um
basically allowed uh corporations to
be you know count their political cor
their political contributions
as free speech and it's gotten much
worse
since then um many
of uh many of the big corporations play
both sides by funding
candidates on on either side and we have
tons
there really ought to be limits and on
any you know sizable donation there
should be like
limits to the point of how much you can
do and there should be you know ways to
make sure that you can't get around
by having all your employees donate in
your name or something like that
so that that is a huge problem
um
ex chrysad says is there something
defective in our politics
or is this the polity that causes us to
put up such really bad candidates
that's a great question i think that
so there's a couple things going on um
one of the problems is that in in the
way our system works right where
leadership develops generally at a lower
level
and then it's going up to higher and
higher levels and eventually like you
become a senator
or a governor and then you can run for
president or things like that
you have to make so many compromises
along the way um that it like think
about illinois politics right when
people were saying about
oh this obama guy hope and change
i was like who the hell thinks that this
guy is going to change
anything he's just another chicago
machine politician
who was you know somebody's favorite
brought in essentially to run against
allen keys
because they needed somebody else who
was african-american to run against him
and he takes orders you know his whole
career from all these these
you know illinois politicians you think
he's actually going to be hope and
change
and he's just another you know another
same type of politician
and sure enough that's that's the way he
behaved you know
big surprise the other problem is that
once people make it into the political
system
and here i'm going to engage in some
some class analysis
they become part of a political class
and there's so many opportunities for
enrichment
you know anybody who thinks that for
example the obamas or the clintons or
the
you know the bushes or any of these
people
have anything in common with with
working people or
even people who are like solidly upper
middle class
you're nuts they they've they've made
their millions
they can continue to make their millions
they can give a speech
and make more money in one speech
than i can in years of work
that's a that's a totally different
reality they can't be expected to have
the interests of of other people uh you
know the majority of people
at heart and it's it's surprising that
that so many of them
uh managed to do some of that so
yeah so that is a big problem um
all right ted says i'm a republican who
voted biotin but i'm so happy
libertarian voters voted third party and
showed it has an impact
this is this is where it gets an
interesting territory i think pretty
soon we're going to see the blame game
getting played
by republicans against libertarians
who are going to be saying they screwed
up the election just like you know
um democrats were so mad at
people who voted for jill stein and the
greens or who voted libertarian
in the last election right because the
libertarian vote in some of those
contested states
is definitely enough that it would have
shifted the state one way or the other
i saw a really funny thing on twitter
where
i don't know who posted it but it was a
libertarian who said if all the
republicans had just voted libertarian
the libertarians would have actually won
and then it showed an electoral vampire
it's all yellow right and you know that
that's a good retort right
um somebody else uh had a nice thing
they chimed in
ayn rand defeated ayn rand um
not all libertarians of course are
randians but there's there's a there's a
significant influence there
yeah you know and it's interesting that
the libertarians looking at the results
and i haven't gone through state by
state
by state i like to do sort of analysis
after elections
um i haven't looked at
exactly what the impact is but it looks
like the libertarians were the only
third party
that really managed to draw a
significant
um significant vote in in most places
the greens were there in some places
constitution party
there's a few other parties but none of
them came anywhere close to the
libertarians
so it's kind of interesting to see all
right um
see what else we got here
um blah blah blah some
back and forth arguments
um eric w did greg talk about how both
parties are co-opted by the ownership
class how could this change will
whatever um
i mean they're they're both beholden you
could say
to um certain corporate interests
and a lot of you know rich families i
would say that
um it depends on what part of the party
you're talking about i mean the tea
party was a reaction against that and
then it got colonized almost immediately
right
um i don't know that that the left wing
of the
democratic party they're usually arguing
about this this being so problematic
you're in the your pocket of the banks
or things like that so
all right uh let's see here
i just jumped a little bit let me
scroll up a little bit uh
a lot of back and forth um
all right so here's a good point by ken
by ken blackwell
thankfully trump was an obvious
incompetent imagine if there had been
someone competent and charismatic there
instead of in 2016 what safeguards could
be put in place to guard against this
that is indeed what a lot of people are
worried about what if somebody mobilizes
the same
forces that trump was was able to
mobilize to beat out all the other
republicans because remember
think about what the primaries were like
in 2016
you know bush uh jeb bush was the front
runner and there were other people like
like rubio and cruz
and trump you know managed to displace
all of them
managed to say things that that you know
were clearly racist
um all sorts of other problematic i mean
he's just
horrible character right and and people
would be like wow
that's that's gotta bury him and then he
got even more support
among republicans and people like a
guest that sells
right and yeah he is he's a mess
he's a businessman who who runs
businesses into the ground and doesn't
pay people
when he's supposed to um he's
mentally he's not not you know not
particularly bright doesn't have a the
capacity to focus his attention
nothing none of this is you know news to
anybody and yet
he was able to be president and dominate
uh
our policy making uh for quite a while
what happens when we get a competent one
to to deal with uh you know that's that
that is a
concern a real worry so
all right um
the game philosopher here's a question
what would cicero say in your opinion on
the election
and its results well that's that's an
interesting thing to ask
because people asked how can you
possibly be supporting biden
you know uh trump is bad but biden is
also bad right
and i and i people brought this up
because you know i do a lot of work
in the the modern stoic movement and
then i said well
what do you think happened in the civil
war did
cicero and cato say oh they're both bad
i
i can't really support either one no
they actually for a while while they
could be they were neutral and then
they're like
caesar is worse gotta side with his
scumbag pompeii
you know uh we'll figure out what to do
after
after the war is done and then they lost
their war right
um i think of it that way
um i mean cicero would look at somebody
like trump and be like
wow i cannot believe that people support
somebody like that you know what does
that say
about their character that they they do
that he'd probably have
some significant complaints about biden
on a lot a lot of counts right
as well so
um
ex-crusade has a policy thing
universalizing housing vouchers rather
than making it first come
first serve would really help a lot of
families um that would that would help a
number of people
yeah um i think this is actually quite
right by blood black life
bla bled back to life
when americans say they fear socialism
what they really mean is they fear
equality
and fairness and i would say that
formally that's not
correct but materially that is correct
much of what gets called socialism
and then attacked for that reason really
is about equality and fairness and this
is where again being a virtue ethicist
universal healthcare not no brainer you
know um
making sure that nobody is starving
no-brainer
you know um especially when we we have
so much
plenty in this country and it wouldn't
ruin the economy to do so
uh making sure that the people mask up
and don't get their fellow citizens sick
no-brainer you know but but people are
like oh that's terrible you know
and that's just a sign of how how
screwed up their thinking is
from a cognitive perspective that they
can't call things what they are
we do have a big problem with this you
know worry about the word
socialism here so all right let's let's
go on um
so andre says uh can you talk about how
to deal with the widespread impression
of this being an illegitimate election
among the trump supporters
eileen trump of my favorite outcome uh
right now
so it wasn't uh uh uh
illegitimate election and the way to
deal with it is to keep saying sorry
buddy
you're wrong about that and
and if you want to like keep on saying
your stuff ways to
to tell them they're wrong i just keep
pushing back and pushing back and
pushing back
and if they want to you know they want
to be crazy which is basically what it
comes down to
you know um then you treat them like
crazies
that's that's all there is to it you
know um
i mean there for some of the people
seeing trump defeated
and slouching around and how petulant
and stuff like that
that's going to make them think a bit
and they're going to come out of some of
their their bravado
because and some of them will also like
see
there will be some court cases and then
you can point out the court cases
getting thrown out over and over again
and then there's the ones who are always
going to be with the you know good old
uh stab in the back you know and
you're never going to convince them
because they're they're
they're so invested in that but they're
going to be a smaller minority
you know and that's what we do
you know i mean how do you treat
children who come up with
crazy ideas do you like just
beat him down do you just say oh i'll
entertain your nutty ideas
or do you do something that's kind of
like well you can think whatever you
like but
the adults over here are going to do
things this way i think that's how we do
it um
oh here's a great one by wavy do you
think the de tocqueville's descriptions
of american culture
in the 19th century still hold up today
some things yes some things know
his his whole discussion about um
american associationism
and intermediate associations i think
has been gutted
our our civic and social life
is very much at the level of
governmentality rather than
you know um people getting together in
that way
um de tocqueville was right in in saying
in democracy in america
that uh america's great sin is how they
how
he was saying the red and the black
races and that
sooner or later america had better
figure out what it's doing to fix that
he's right about that
i think that that what he was claiming
about you know like for example french
democracy when people would have a
squabble they'd immediately turn to the
state
i think that has become the de facto for
both the republican and the
the democratic party the republicans
used to be a party of limited government
that's not the case anymore they love
governmentality so long as it serves
the purposes that they want um so they
aren't really a party of limited
government
and the tocqueville thought that
americans could kind of manage their own
affairs
so both parties are devoted to like you
know
taking hold power and doing things with
it
um let's see here
doo doo doo
try to find somebody who haven't i
haven't taken a question from
yet before um
so i i'm not monetizing dissent says
trump is the spectacle incarnate capital
accumulated to the point that it becomes
a pure image if you accept the
principles of capitalism trump
figures are inevitable yeah i'm not
so sure about that that media theory
stuff um i think there's probably more
going on uh than that oh here's a good
policy question from xenocrat what do
you think about expanding the supreme
court if you're for it how would you
justify it
i think if the democrats want to expand
the supreme court i'm cool with that the
republicans
played so much politics with courts over
the years i don't think they have a leg
to stand on
you know um the fact that they held up a
supreme court appointment just so that
they could get their own person in
once they crossed that line and you know
this is this is a broader issue too i'm
going to talk about so
i've been observing a breakdown in our
political processes
really since i started paying attention
to it i would say you know
from the 1990s onward where both sides
would do something and you're like
man you shouldn't do that you you should
i know it's
it's going to get you a temporary
advantage but you're
you're starting to do things that are
really clearly partisan
and when the next party comes into power
they're going to do exactly the same
thing
and you're really not going gonna have a
moral right to complain about that
although you will [ __ ] and whine about
it
um and you're doing inevitable damage to
the to the whole
system itself and for people like me who
don't belong to either of your parties
you know what you're showing us is that
we can't trust either of you
and that it really is just becoming
hyper partisan
so i think that what the republicans
have been doing over the last you know
essentially decade in terms of court
appointments as much as possible holding
them up and then you know
shoving as many people in um
i mean it makes sense from a position of
of expediency of just getting power but
it's done so much damage to
the republic uh and to the capacity for
you know sides like respecting certain
boundaries
they don't have anything to complain
about and so i don't think there has to
be a justification for it quite frankly
i think once you've started playing that
much politics you don't get to complain
you know so that's you know that's what
i think about that
and that's a broader issue let's see if
i can take one more
question from somebody else who hasn't
uh
said something previously because then
we're gonna bring this to a close
because i gotta
get on with work for the day um
who is a new voice in here um
well i don't think alex has said
anything but he just says my libertarian
friends are telling me this is
happening but i'm not sure what that's
referring to
let's see if i can find somebody else
uh who's got i haven't done
uh matthias asks is capitalism pushing
something like the chinese model for the
us i don't think so
um capitalism by itself is an
abstraction
okay so here's something i could i could
go out on uh
jeff webber i know you're a fan of dune
any other fiction that touched on
politics that you would suggest
yeah i mean there's there's all sorts of
um
speculative fiction that touches on
politics uh philip k
dick's novels are you know there's lots
of discussions about what's going on
in in political systems there right
ranging from like alternate histories uh
like um
uh blanking and it's the one of the
nazis
the japanese that's one of my favorite
novels by him but there's all sorts of
ones as well but you know i would say
you know provided mankind actually
survives and makes it out to the stars
think about cj
chera's alliance union universe there's
a lot of really interesting political
discussion going on
and there as well as a lot of technical
discussion um i i almost joked at one
point that you almost needed to put a
spreadsheet together to understand
exactly what's going on
down below station um yeah i think
you know ursa kayla green as well uh
somebody who is approaching political
questions
this will be something that we're
talking about in in
the worlds of speculative fiction later
on this month uh
at the end of the month there's there's
a lot of um a lot of authors who are
working with things that we're i mean
george r or martin game of thrones right
there's a lot of
really interesting political discussions
it's important not to
just get into the like uh
sort of dark lord versus you know
plucky hobbit characters you know good
versus evil thing i would say
but there are we we also do have to
recognize when there genuinely
is evil at play um
that's one of the things that i
particularly liked about
um the man in the high castle that's the
name yeah
in the book not the not the amazon tv
series in the book there's a clear
recognition that the japanese although a
militaristic society are much more
humane
than the nazis who have managed to take
over things and who
are driven by sort of a nihilistic
uh and opportunistic will will to
power um and have to be stopped
you know so i'd say there's lots of uh
interesting speculative fiction
that we could look to much of it is not
directly applicable to our
immediate situation but it's it's worth
reading it doesn't
automatically have to provide us with
clear
solutions so all right on that i am
going to
end this um thanks for all of your
questions comments
and um hopefully
we you know make it through all of this
and
there won't be hopefully a lot of
post-election violence and we can have a
transition and then start figuring out
where we need to go next